hey guys mkbhd here and today i have a
pretty nice tool to show you guys by the
folks over at in sync no not the musical
group i swear uh but when i first heard
of nsync i saw this
it's okay to break up with dropbox and i
was like whoa whoa like who do these
guys think they are i love dropbox you
know and if you've never heard of
dropbox it's this really easy to use
convenient cloud kind of storage system
where you save a file on your computer
and a copy of it appears on every other
device you have linked to dropbox insync
is like dropbox with google docs so this
software links your computer to your
google account so you can throw anything
in this folder and that's game and it'll
be uploaded and synced with google docs
so let's check out the interface
basically here's what it looks like on
the web it looks just like dropbox and
you can go through all your files and
folders just like you could on your
computer and just like if you double
click them if you click them here it'll
go ahead and open up that file and it'll
pop up in google docs so if you have any
images or things like that they preview
right by opening in google docs you also
have a number of things that you can do
you can hit the drop down to get a link
to share the file or view other versions
of it and also you have the number of
people who can view the file in the blue
box on the left and more info about the
file to the right so it's a pretty
pretty basic organized structure here so
here on the desktop you get an in-sync
folder that you can put all your
documents in so anything you put here
will get synced with google docs really
fast but yeah it operates just like a
normal computer a normal file manager on
mac or windows so if you change let's
say this notepad file here it syncs i
don't know if you saw it really really
ridiculously fast it syncs with google
and of course when you go to google docs
on your web browser you have the
beautiful google design and the neat
organization of all your precious
priceless files so glorious
so here's that text file that i changed
unfortunately you can't preview
txt files that will go ahead and
download it here and you'll see that it
is already that updated text file this
is brilliant
so why would you choose this over
dropbox you know both are on mac and
windows what's the difference uh the
short answer is storage both google and
dropbox offer the first gigabyte free
but after that google is way cheaper all
the way uh way cheaper than dropbox
storage i'm talking like 20 gigs for
five bucks a year it's a no-brainer so
go ahead and give this video a like if
you enjoyed you can try everything out
below happy new year and i will talk to
all you guys in the next video thanks
for watching
peace
you